G
FUN OF DEMOCRATS.
CHARLIE HURT IS WITH
"THE WASHINGTON TIMES" HE JOINS
US TO ASSESS BUT WE JUST LEARNED
ABOUT THIS.
ON ONE LEVEL IT'S RIDICULOUS
THAT HER BIGGEST LAW ENFORCEMENT
AGENCY IS TRYING TO FORCE PEOPLE
TO TOPS TELLING JOKES BUT ON THE
OTHER HAND THIS IS A CRIME OF
SOME MISSING SOMETHING.
>> ABSOLUTELY NO DOUBT ABOUT IT.
IT'S A CLEAR VIOLATION OF THE
FIRST AMENDMENT TO.
I THINK THIS LATEST DUMP
REVEALS -- LITERALLY THERE WERE
SO MANY INTERACTIONS BETWEEN THE
FBI AND OTHER BRANCHES OF THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT AND TWITTER
WHERE THEY GOT TOGETHER TO
COLLUDE ON WHAT WAS ALLOWED TO
BE SHARED IN THE PLATFORM AND
WHAT WAS NOT ALLOWED, THEY WERE
ACTUALLY OPENING UP NEW BACK
CHANNELS ON PLATFORMS THAT I HAD
NEVER HEARD OF BEFORE.
MANY VIEWERS HAVE NEVER HEARD OF
BEFORE IN ORDER FOR THEM TO KEEP
IN CONSTANT TOUCH WITH ONE
ANOTHER.
THE THING TO REMEMBER IS IF THIS
WERE HAPPENING DURING THE
PENTAGON PAPERS AND WE WERE
REALIZING THIS DEGREE OF
COLLUSION BETWEEN THE FBI, CIA,
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT, AND
"THE NEW YORK TIMES" OR IF WE
WOKE UP TODAY AND IF THERE WAS
THIS LEVEL OF COLLUSION BETWEEN
FOX NEWS AND THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT IN THE MIDDLE OF AN
ELECTION TO DETERMINE WHAT WE
WOULD OR WOULD NOT REPORT, THERE
WOULD RIGHTFULLY BE AN OUTCRY
LIKE WE'VE NEVER SEEN BEFORE.
YET IT HAPPENS HERE, AN ALARMING
NUMBER OF THE MAINSTREAM MEDIA
ARE LIKE WHATEVER.
>> Tucker: THEY ARE SOCK
PUPPETS FOR HEADQUARTERS,
WORKING ON BEHALF OF THE STATE
AGAINST THE POPULATION OF THE
COUNTRY.
THE FBI WAS WORKING FOR THE
POLITICAL PARTY, HOW IS THIS
DIFFERENT FROM WHAT THE SECRET
POLICE DOING AUTHORITARIAN
COUNTRIES?
>> ABSOLUTELY NOT DIFFERENT AT
ALL.
WHAT IS AMUSING HERE IS AS SOON
AS ELON MUSK STARTS KICKING
JOURNALISTS OFF OF TWITTER FOR
DOXXING HIM, THEY START
SQUEALING LIKE A STUCK PIGS.
OF COURSE THESE SAME PEOPLE
NEVER SAID A WORD, NOT A PEEP
OUT OF THEM WHEN THE GOVERNMENT
IN COLLUSION WITH TWITTER BEGAN
SILENCING DOCTORS AND SCIENTISTS
AT THE HEIGHT OF THE PANDEMIC.
NOT A WORD FROM THESE PEOPLE.
THE IDEA -- WE ARE IN A BUSINESS
WHERE WE ARE SUPPOSED TO BE THE
PROTECTORS OF THE
FIRST AMENDMENT?
YOU'RE ON YOUR OWN, THESE PEOPLE
ARE NOT PROTECTING THE
FIRST AMENDMENT FOR ANYONE BUT
THEMSELVES AND FOR THE MOST
POWERFUL GOVERNMENT ON THE
PLANET.
>> Tucker: THEY ARE LITERALLY
FBI INFORMANTS POSING AS